essentially I believe that we are
already in a dream and we will be waking
up from it in the DLC specifically
micha's dream or nightmare depending on
your outlook I think it's possible that
we as the character were created by
Micha to wake him up or it's possible
that we are Mika and need to wake
ourselves up from it in order to well
that's what I'm not sure of yet the
easiest theory on why we'd want to wake
up from this dream is so that we can
stop Godwin from taking over the urg
tree and the lands between and also Moog
from doing whatever the heck he's doing
with micha's body this is all in the
basis of the shadow of the UR tree image
that the UR Trey is being strangled by
Godwin's death blight I believe in the
DLC will have the choice to either let
Godwin continue his deadly influence or
we will stop him and have ourselves or
Micha plant a new tree to replace the
old like michas Halo tree